[Music]
the
Francis Li grew up in the city of st.
Louis in a very very large family I
think he had 13 siblings grew up in a
very modest middle-class neighborhood in
the southwest part of the city and
what's known as the 23rd board his
father was a politician is also a
restaurateur so he grew up in politics
in 1995 he ran for president the Board
of Aldermen against I think five other
aldermen and he got more votes and all
the rest of them combined became
president of the board in 2001 he ran
for mayor and beat the incumbent mayor
and the former mayor so we beat two
mayors and again had more votes than
both of them combined under mayor slay
there's been sixteen billion dollars in
economic development and that's big
projects like City Arts River and more
modest economic development projects
like the rebirth of these buildings for
the chest hall of fame and the chess
club he also did a lot for people
education was one of his top priorities
he created a process and opened more
than 20 charter schools to give parents
in the city whose kids are either
trapped in bad schools or who would be
forced to move out of the city to get a
good public education give them a choice
and stay in the city of st. Louis I
think he's been very courageous he's
been quite a leader he's faced some very
difficult challenges over the years he's
had problems with fire departments with
unions and he took them all on he always
emerged victorious the city is better
off and you know I think everybody
admires his leadership his
forthrightness is honesty being mayor
was never about him it wasn't about his
interests or what was important to him
it was what is good for this city so
when Rex and Jeanne talked about chess
as a way to engage our children more to
give them more to do after school to
give them something to do that will
engage their mind to give them something
that they can be proud of if they're not
an athlete they're not a football player
a baseball player that appealed to him
well mayor slay was very quickly
supportive he told me some years ago he
says any chess event you have I will
shell a park which I thought was
remarkable dedication that he was well
in tune with what our purpose was with
our effort getting in front kids and
getting into schools need to first very
supportive with that the idea that part
of our brand was going to be that we
were the chest capital of the United
States and one of the most important
places in the world for the game of
chess something you know that attracts
people who are cerebral people who are
strategic people who are college
educated was something that was very
appealing to him and he got it right
away embraced it and you know gladly did
so the Mara was in the Chess Club here a
year or two back and so let's sit down
and play a game I made a move and he
said I'm not sure what to do so I made a
move for him and then I made another
move for myself and then somebody
standing behind him said move the night
and the mayor said which one's the night
I bust out laughin nearly fell off my
chair mayor slay you not only are the
longest-serving there in our city's
history but you are going to go down in
history as the best mayor or city has
ever had our city has been fortunate
that you have been willing to make the
commitment and the sacrifice to be our
mayor for so long you will be sorely
missed and your legacy will be something
that many generations from now people
will still be talking about so good luck
in the next phase of your life and we're
going to miss you as our mayor mayor
slay I would say thank you very much for
your friendship and your leadership
you've meant a lot to me personally even
a lot for all the things that I am
trying to do you've been a big help in
all those efforts and the city is going
to miss you and I'm going to miss you
and the only thing you have left to do
is to learn how to play chess thank
[Music]